hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime outpro and the dark lord
of quirks all for one just transformed
again and he is stronger than ever he's
also looking like the guy who stole your
girl in high school for some reason but
the heroes are not done yet as a true
Titan Rises to take on the dark Lore
wanna wall for one's most powerful
allies just betrayed him toga is losing
her mind like even more than usual and
things are spitting out of control in
mha and then there's the crazy truth
about the other God of quirks Deku so
let's get into it you guys know the
drill if you enjoy our mha videos and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment right now it
only takes you a second but it helps us
with that YouTube algorithm and if you
are one of the over 50 of people who
watch our videos but haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a big favor
and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications subscribing
on YouTube is of course completely free
but it helps me out a lot finally this
video will contain mha manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in the previous chapter the
heroes and hero students were slowly
turning the tide of the battle as inasa
was able to neutralize the threat of
toga and Sad Man's parade Endeavor was
keeping Dobby busy and everyone else was
engaging over one the heroes are all
aware by now that they cannot let all
for one reach shigaraki so they were
giving it their all to stop him from
escaping goonga all for one was still
feeling pretty confident and he didn't
seem too bothered by the fact that his
time was running out and his body was
rewinding itself out of existence but
then this confident attitude seemed to
suddenly change as he came face to face
with full power Dark Shadow the chapter
Ended as the gigantic Dark Shadow
descended upon all for one in an
absolutely epic fashion the latest
chapter begins by shifting Focus back to
toga who for the last few chapters has
has been kept at Bay by inasa's work but
as I said in my video on the previous
chapter we cannot just assume that inasa
will keep toga neutralized forever and
the new chapter reminds us right away of
what an enormous threat she still is up
to this point toga had been making
clones of twice and then those clones
have been replicating endlessly creating
Sad Man's parade but now toga starts
making clones of other people including
shigaraki all for one and Dobby now this
is of course a terrifying development a
mountain of twice clones is scary enough
on its own but imagine multiple
shigarakis all for ones and dobbies
using all of their overpowered quirks on
the heroes I mean that's game over
instant ggs luckily for the heroes when
the shigaraki Clone attempts to use
Decay nothing happens and that is when
tsuyu realizes that toga most likely
isn't able to replicate the quirks of
the other villains only 2 wisest Quirk
we know that in the past Tolga told
ochako that she was able to use her
Quirk zero gravity because she is one of
the people that toga loves and since
toga also loved twice she can also use
his Quirk and this limitation that toga
has the ability to use the quirks only
of the people she loves appears to
extend to her transformation into twice
it seems that toga doesn't love the
other members of the league of villains
at least not to the same extent and so
her clones cannot duplicate their quirks
even though the original twice had the
ability to make his clones use the
quirks of their original owners toga
can't seem to do it meanwhile toga
herself is an absolute wreck and she is
losing her mind like even more than
she's already lost it if that makes
sense she doesn't quite understand why
she can't use the quirks of say
shigaraki and Dabi because she feels
that she really does love them but it
just isn't working she even tried this
before she tested it out but she
couldn't get the other clones to use
their quirks she was hoping that things
had now changed but they haven't and her
other clones still can't use the quirks
of The Originals toga is crying and she
seems to be full of Despair she knows
that if the original twice was here he
could have been able to copy the quirks
but she can't she can't fully become
twice no matter how hard she tries and
this seems to be driving her mad these
Heroes killed twice one of the people
she truly loved and she can't even bring
herself to destroy them as she faces off
against the twice clones ochako spots
the original clone toga herself and both
ochako and tsuyu know that with how
unstable toga is things could change at
any moment and anytime she might decide
that she does love the other villains
and then she would instantly be able to
use their quirks so they have to stop
the original toga right here and now I
mean from a writing perspective
horikoshi had to give this limitation to
toga imagine if she just started off the
fight by cloning a bunch of shigarakis
or all for ones and using their quirks
the villains would have won way too
easily so this limitation had to be put
in place back in the fight against all
for one tokoyami is still using Dark
Shadow to attack the arch villain Hawks
tells him to stay strong and keep going
they need to keep crushing and
destroying over one until his body is
gone his body will rewind itself out of
existence eventually they just need to
hold out for long enough to make sure
that happens before all for one has a
chance to make contact with shigaraki
all the other Heroes and hero students
are trying to send their attacks over
Dark Shadow to create an aura of
Darkness around him and make him even
stronger but in the end it's no use all
for one manages to create a powerful
explosion that pushes Dark Shadow back
and then we see that all for one's body
has transformed again all for one's body
is continuing to rewind itself and he
now looks much younger I'm not sure how
old he is exactly but he looks like he
might be a teenager the same age as a UA
student not only does all for one look
younger but he appears to be even more
powerful now and he may be strong enough
to overpower and escape the heroes he
manages to push the heroes back despite
their best efforts and he is now flying
away from them and towards Shiga
location and if that wasn't bad enough
things suddenly appear to get even worse
for the heroes as he's flying through
the air all for one sees giganto Makia
in the distance and he knows that this
is the perfect opportunity to get away
from the heroes for good as Machias
master all for one orders him to destroy
the heroes while he takes off in search
of shigaraki but just when you think
that all for one might have won this
battle after all we all know how
insanely strong machia is it turns out
that the heroes still have an ace up
their sleeve instead of obeying over
one's orders Makia grabs an entire
mountain and throws it right at all for
one stopping him in his tracks we then
learned what the heroes are really up to
the heroes are using Shinzo to control
machia and my guess is they're using
both his Quirk and his Persona chords to
mimic all for one's voice I don't think
shinso Quirk on its own is reliable
enough to manipulate a powerful creature
like Makia because we all know what
happened when he tried to use it on Deku
so I'm guessing he is also using Persona
chords to mimic the voice of makia's
Master since all for one is much younger
now he looks completely different than
he did before and he probably sounds
different too he doesn't have any device
to help him breathe and stuff like that
it's likely that Makia doesn't even
recognize his master at this point and
so instead of obeying his master all for
one Makia is now obeying shinso and
fighting on the side of the heroes and
on that shocking note this chapter comes
to an end okay now clearly a bunch of
important stuff happened here but first
I want to address the whole Dark Shadow
situation from the comments on my
previous review I got the feeling that a
lot of you guys were hoping that dark
shadow really would have some real
impact on this battle some were even
thinking that maybe Dark Shadow could
defeat all for one now that he's been
weekend clearly that was not to be as I
predicted in the other video I mean we
have to be realistic here as much as I
love my boy the chicken of Darkness
tokoyami he is not a main character he
is a supporting character and in a
Shonen series you're not likely to see a
supporting character delivering the
decisive blow to a major villain like
all for one now to be fair to tokoyami
he did unleash A Massive Attack upon all
for one but it seems that in that very
moment all for one's body was rewound
again and he became younger not only did
he become visibly younger but he also
seemed to be considerably stronger than
just moments before I'm guessing that
all his injuries and fatigue disappeared
due to the rewinding and so now he is
completely fresh also since he is now
around the age of a teenager he is
probably at his peak in terms of energy
stamina and so on so yeah Dark Shadow
tried but the timing just wasn't good
enough still big respect to tokwami for
learning to control Dark Shadow so well
and so effectively now let's talk about
the giant Makia twist which really is a
huge deal personally I did not think
that the heroes would ever risk letting
Makia out of captivity after everything
that happened during the Paranormal
Liberation War Arc but I guess the
heroes felt like they had to take the
risk and they were confident that shinso
would be able to control this gigantic
monster this is very much a high risk
High reward move because yeah if the
heroes can effectively control machia he
will be a massive asset against the
villains he might even prove to be the
thing that prevents all for one from
reuniting with shigaraki and completing
his master plan so that is the potential
High reward of this move preventing all
for one from ever reaching shigaraki
thanks to gigantomakia the high risk
aspect is the possibility that all for
one will figure out a way to snap Makia
out of of Shinto's control and to place
him under his own command once more if
you thought that the heroes were in
trouble before just imagine what will
happen to them if all for one reasserts
his control over machia and then orders
him to kill the heroes while he goes off
to find shigaraki if that happens I
genuinely don't see how the heroes can
win this Dobby is still out there and
rampaging toga is still there using Sad
Man's parade and now gigantomakia like I
said I really hope that the heroes know
what they're doing here because as much
as they might have just saved themselves
in the short run by bringing Makia out
that very decision could absolutely
destroy them in the long run if all for
one is able to outsmart them what do you
guys think will happen with Makia will
he continue serving shinsel or will all
for one find a way to bring him back to
the dark side and if he does what
happens next are the heroes finished
speaking of the heroes being finished
what will happen with toga she is
becoming increasingly mentally unstable
which is saying a lot considering how
messed up she already is even under
normal circumstances right now she's
struggling because she can't seem to
fully become twice but what if she does
have some sort of mental break and
develops a split personality would that
other personality the twice personality
then be able to use the K blue flame and
all for one's insane quirks against the
heroes that would be an absolute
disaster for every hero and hero student
at gunga although the heroes seem to
have regained the initiative on the
battlefield it feels like things could
go terribly wrong at any moment toga is
somehow learning to use the other quirks
would spell disaster for the heroes
Makia breaking away from Shinto's
control would also spell disaster for
the heroes Dobby somehow defeating
Endeavor and rejoining the main battle
would also spell disaster for the heroes
not to mention that young all for one is
a complete wild card since he now seems
to be even stronger than he was before
so even though the heroes seem to be
doing well at this moment the situation
is extremely fragile and very fluid
things could change drastically at
virtually any moment with all that said
this chapter has convinced me of one
thing all for one will definitely make
it to the main Battlefield where Deku
and shigaraki are currently facing off
and he will meet his ultimate fate there
not here in gunga first up the fact that
all for one is now so young kind of
flips the script on the narrative that
he is the old generation and Deku and
shigaraki are the Next Generation all
for one doesn't want to accept that his
time is over so it makes sense for him
to engage in a final showdown with the
Next Generation before all is said and
done second I am convinced that
shigaraki was born quirkless and that
the K was secretly transferred onto him
by all for one without him even
realizing it if I am right this will be
revealed during the final showdown and
it makes sense for both all for one and
shigaraki to be there in the flesh for
the big reveal I have a new video in the
works that will be coming out soon and
that covers this Theory so if that's
something you're interested in
definitely subscribe and hit the Bell to
turn on all notifications I think all
for one will somehow find a way to get
to decline shigaraki and he will try to
place his Quirk factor into his vessel
he will ultimately fail to regain
control of shigaraki but I do wonder
what will happen before all for one
fails and dies will he place his Quirk
factor into shigaraki and then we'll
witness an epic internal struggle
between the two of them maybe even a
battle that Deku and the vestiges can
join because the vested world of one for
all and all for one seem to be linked or
maybe all for one will try to place his
Quirk Factor inside of Deku instead
turning Deku into a quirk god with the
power of one for all and all for one at
the same time but if that did happen to
Deku then would he be the same Deku we
know or would all for one's Quirk Factor
begin influencing his behavior and
personality those are the questions that
I really want hodikoshi to answer very
soon what do you guys think will happen
let me know Down Below in the comment
section of my last review video someone
even mentioned that all for one may try
to place his Quirk factor into bakugou
since bakugou is now injured so he
wouldn't be able to resist effectively
and if that did happen then all for one
took bakugou's body he could then use
super regeneration on bakugou's body and
bakugou would go back to normal at least
physically but he might then be evil
bakugou bakugo under the control of all
for one honestly there are so many
interesting options for what might
happen next and I can't wait to see
where horikoshi plans to take the story
from here if you guys enjoyed this video
leave a quick like right now it helps me
out a lot and of course don't forget to
subscribe and hit the notification Bell
you can also hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at animeoproar as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya Space Cowboy boys